hey everybody Sean McGinnis and Tom
mcshay here at e3 2014 and Tom here has
just had the chance to check out the new
DLC for dark souls to the Lost crowns
first question how does one lose a crown
they you don't have a strap when you
work it just sits on your head so course
is gonna fall Krantz too big just Falls
right off and doesn't know it's too big
and it just got to go to anyways so it's
more than just about the process of how
one might lose a crown it's also dark
souls 3 how it relates to dark souls uh
y-you their first question I don't know
the answer so I did I did ask them so
Tory see the abyss was the only dlc for
dark souls original and you need to do
like kill a crystal golem in the Dukes
archive and then go back to another area
and talk to us what it's really hard to
access yeah and I said this time it's
also going to be like there's a couple
steps you have to do to access this when
it finally comes out and when you
finally purchase it you might not be
able to play it right away so this is
not access from the main menu oh my lord
it's here's some hidden door that wasn't
accessible before and now you can
finally go through that kind of it
sounds like something about a different
so how does the actual combat
exploration compare what how would you
describe the experience of finding a
lost crown uh dark souls in it made it
feels it feels very dark souls I mean
unlike ettore to the abyss which starts
with like a chimera boss fight and then
you're in this forest like this didn't
have that visual or visceral impact
right away around like thrust into
something great which is a little
disappointing by the weirdest part
though is at the end I cross this bridge
and there's like this big stone door at
the end uh-huh and I get to it and
nothing happened but is it a puzzle do
you need to do something or does the
game say stay tuned for lost crowns part
2 not not nothin nothin happen to see
well thats dark souls oh that's a very
obtuse you know very cryptic series so
what did you think overall thumbs up
thumbs down attended a thumbs up I mean
I don't know I don't know if it'll be a
touristy the basement more dark souls is
always a good thing alright cool so
that's the Dark Souls 2
the lost crowns DLC courtesy of Tom
mcshea stay tuned for more III coverage
Oh